[Music]
well uh
this happened with desantis they're
still like you said it's great you
brought that up great segway he didn't
even know this was coming check this out
i'll tell you what they're saying once
they uh
yeah i think that's all just them
synthetically trying to create
narratives so they're accusing him just
you know the question
they're accusing him of him giving
public he gave
he says he gave publix exclusivity to
give the vaccine
because he says they donated listen to
this a hundred thousand dollars to him
first off a hundred thousand dollars to
this tim is nothing it's
nothing the reason the public's got the
vaccine
is because there's one every 10 feet in
florida it's the biggest supermarket
chain they have the most brick and
mortar places in florida of anything of
anything banks
of anything is a publix and they have a
pharmacy which means that they have
people they are qualified
they're equipped to do it yeah exactly
yeah you're right because honestly
if he was supposed to if he was to say
okay uh
all the cvs's can have it
it's a [ __ ] to find a cvs in florida
because every time you're looking for a
cvs there's a walgreens
it's a [ __ ] to find a walgreens because
every time you look at for a walgreens
you find a ces
but he's right it there's when you see a
shopping center that has a cvs
oral walgreens in it publix guess what
the [ __ ] in that shop
100 a so this is what happened he had a
back and forth of the report um
and i don't know if it's meant to be
positive or negative most of the
national narratives that the corporate
press does about me tend to be negative
and i reject them
uh so i'll let them do whatever they
want but that's all them
doing it on me i think that people
understand florida's done a lot better
than anyone predicted a year ago
that's just the reality and you know i
had to make a lot of tough decisions
and i think folks have noticed that but
you know you look at the main decisions
we
all had to make how do you handle
nursing homes
we protected nursing homes we didn't
unlike
that's a shock that's a cheap shot yes
yeah
the patient i'm sorry i didn't uh kill
any old people and sexually harass two
dozen women but hey
i'm not calling anyone out specifically
into nursing homes like some of these
you start
really imitating them hey oh bada bing
let me grab some titties
how do you handle nursing homes we
protected nursing homes
we didn't ship the patients into nursing
homes like some of these other states
we were able to reduce okay that was a
little more specific
he ends it with and como's a [ __ ] i
like i really are now waiting i i really
am expecting
the next thing out of his mouth to be
like yeah like old governor titty
grabber up there in new york
sticking guns in people's [ __ ] and
then we could go oh he watches the show
bought a bing nipple rings over here
that's right my dream is for us to
someday meet ron desantis
and have him go by the way the guns and
the [ __ ] but it was fun
i could never see that one it was very
mortality and mitigate as a result oh so
he'll treat us like every other famous
youtuber that listens to us
i can't tell anybody but but your shield
is good your show's good thank you for
the substantial donation yes thank you
and then you're like wow he's never
gonna call us back is he
we just wasted five thousand dollars
didn't we [ __ ]
for veal for shitty veal yeah
you look at the schools probably one of
the most important decisions any
governor can make
are you going to get the kids in school
are you going to have them toil for a
year
we were right on the schools obviously
having the economy open
we see the benefits of that and then
most recently
putting seniors first on vaccinations i
mean that is going to have a positive
impact on mortality oh did you see what
happened i i there's a little i want to
get to the point of this but
this reminds me so desantis every week
has been lowering the age by five years
so now it's at 50. if you're 50 and
under you could get it statewide
dennings the mayor here in orlando here
was like you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to make it 40. if you're 40
you get the vaccine
i ran out no desantis came out and goes
you can't do that only i could do that
and denning's had to go up i had to put
it back to 50.
sorry dennis has been eating a
dick lately quality and so i think that
this is something that that folks
appreciate
uh seeing leadership but it's really
just me doing my job and trying to get
uh
do the best i can for the people of
florida and that's all i'm going to be
continuing to do
this next question is so she you can't
hear her but she's asking about
reports that you gave publix exclusivity
for a hundred thousand so you know what
she's about to ask
sure
so first of all that what you're saying
is wrong that's that that's a fake
narrative
so first of all when we did the the
first pharmacies that had it were cvs
and walgreens
and they had a long-term care mission so
they were going to the long-term care
facilities
they got vaccine in the middle of
december they started going to the
long-term care facilities
the third week of december to do ltc's
so that was their mission
that was very important and we trusted
them to do that
as we got into january we wanted to
expand the distribution points
so yes you had the counties you had some
drive-through sites you had hospitals
that were doing a lot
but we wanted to get it into communities
more so we reached out to other retail
pharmacies publix walmart
obviously cvs and walgreens had to
finish that mission and we said we're
going to we're going to use you as soon
as you're done with that
for the publix they were the first one
to raise their hands say they were ready
to go
and you know what we did it on a trial
basis i had three counties
i actually showed up that weekend and
talked to seniors across
four different publics how was the
experience is this good should you think
this is the way to go
and it was a hundred percent positive so
we expanded it
and then folks liked it and i can tell
you if you look at a place like palm
beach county
they were kind of struggling at first in
terms of the senior numbers
i went i met with the county mayor i met
with the administrator i met with all
the folks at palm beach county and i
said
here's some of the options we can do
more drive-through sites we can give
more to hospitals
we can do the publics we can do this
they calculated that 90
of their seniors live within a mile and
a half of a public 90
of everybody in florida lives by a
publix
i mean it's insane again i could throw a
rock in any direction
and i will hit a publix and they said we
think that would be the easiest thing
for our residents
so we did that and what ended up
happening was you had 65 publics in palm
beach
palm beach is one of the biggest
counties one of the most elderly
counties
we've done almost 75 percent of the
seniors in palm beach and the reason is
because you have the strong retail
footprint
so our uh whey has been multi-faceted it
has worked
and we're also now very much expanding
cvs and walgreens
now that they've completed the long-term
care mission yes
and it's wrong it's wrong it's a fake
narrative i just disabused you of the
narrative
and you don't care about the facts
because obviously i laid it out for you
in a way
that is irrefutable and so it's clearly
not
no no no you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong yes sir
by the way can i say that i love that
he's using fake narrative instead of
fake news
i love that they too they write snaps at
a reporter
whereas i'm sorry but i think in the
last four years we've all watched
many many a politician on both sides
mind you
quote unquote snap i think we've seen
plenty of snapping correct
yes andrew cuomo has basically snapped
there's been a few people that have
[ __ ] snapped
that's not snapping no yeah no you just
simply don't want to listen because
you're a woman probably and
it was i just laid it out for you in an
entire [ __ ] thing and you just
completely blew it off but like yeah
dude
he's just he i give it to a man he's
calm
he knows how to stay calm yeah he he
really does
um he's better than trump as far as
not getting sucked into every little
petty [ __ ] thing like that was one of
trump's real downfalls was
like you know what emma says you know
that one reporter that said one thing to
me earlier thursday
i'm gonna call him all weekend on
twitter and you're like
i mean maybe call him one time and then
we got all this other stuff
nope oh we i'm gonna tag him every hour
and go hey boy
it's not gonna look good